All right. So why don't we recap what
we've discussed in this lesson. First, we discussed
the components to an effective information visualization. They
were visual cues, the coordinate system, the scale and
data types, and the context. After that, we
dived a little bit deeper into the various
different ways that we can encode data visually.
These included its size, position, color, and many more.
We also discussed various scales and data types such as numerical,
categorical, and time-series. We took
a deeper dive into time-series, since that's what
most of the data for our assignment will look
like. And finally, we went over the basics
of creating graphics using ggplot, a library for
Python. For this week's assignment, you'll use what
we've learned in this lesson. That is the basic
principles of data visualization and the basics of
how to create a graphic in ggplot. You'll create
a few basic visualizations that describe things about the
New York City subway. So, you'll want to communicate to
people our statistical findings from assignment 3, but also
maybe just some general information regarding the subway. Ridership
at various hours of the day, how many people
are going into and out of different stations, etc.